صارت سفيره السعوديه لدى واشنطن ريما بنت
بندر رائدى الفضاء السعوديين على القرني
وريان برناوي في مركز التحكم الخاص بمهمه
سبيس اكس التي تنظمها وكاله الفضاء ناسا
قالت الاميره ريما في تغريده لها انها
قامت بجوله في مرافق المركز وشاهدت رائدي
الفضاء السعوديين خلال التدريب واشادت
بالرائده ريان التي تعد اول رائده فضاء
عربيه مسلم
14 تجربه بحثيه تجريها الهيئه السعوديه
للفضاء للتاهيل رائدى الفضاء السعوديين
ريان برناوي وعلي القرني لاستكشاف وتطوير
مجالات مختلفه قبل المغادره الى محطه
الفضاء الدوليه في الثاني عشر من مايو
المقبل التجارب البحريه مصممه عبر علماء
وباحثين بهدف اجتياز متطلبات التاهيل
لبرنامج رواد الفضاء السعوديين واستيفائي
معايير التقييم
من احد مختبرات الفضاء في رياض انضم الينا
مراسل العربيه نصفيا مرحبا هاني كل سنه
وانت طيب حدثنا اكثر عن هذه التجارب التي
تقام لرواد الفضاء
نعم خالد اهلا بك واهلا بمشاهدي قناه
العربيه اليوم نتحدث عن انا السعوديه تطمح
بوصول بحوثها الى الفضاء واقامه ايضا
تجارب هي اربعه عشر تجربه بحثيه سوف
تستخدمها السعوديه وسوف تقوم بها من خلال
عمليه تدريب لراعيدي الفضاء الذين سوف
يقومون بتجربه هذه البحوث من هذه البحوث
هي في مجالات عده طبعا ولكن اليوم نتحدث
عن المجالات الطبيه وتحديدا من داخل هذا
المختبر الواقع في مستشفى الملكه او مركز
الابحاث في مستشفى الملك فيصل للبحوث
العلميه يقوم هؤلاء العلماء وكذلك
الاطباء وكذلك بعض البروفيسوريون
الموجودين في هذا المختبر باقامه تجربه
البحوث العلميه عموما في هذا الامر سوف
يتحدث معي ضيفي وهو الدكتور خالد ابو خبر
وهو رئيس قسم الجزيئات الطبيه وكذلك
الحيويه في مستشفى الملك فيصل اليوم نتكلم
عن بحوث الطبيه وفي مجالات اخرى ولكن
دائما نتحدث عن البحوث الطبيه ما هي هذه
البحوث كيف سوف تقدمونها كيف سوف يتم
تجربتها في الفضاء كيف سوف يتم ايضا عملها
وايجاد هذه النتائج من خلال البحوث
احنا نستخدم نماذج خلويه للمرض
وبالاخص معرفه استجابه الخلايا المناعيه
للالتهاب
وفي نفس الوقت نفهم التغييرات في عمق عمر
الحمل الربو المراسل وكيفيه ايضا
الاستجابه للعلاج الدوائي عشان نقارن
بينهم بين الفضاء وبين وبين
وبين الارض يعني كمقارنه نعم يعني يا
دكتور اليوم نتكلم بشكل سلس يعني اليوم
انتم تقومون بالتجارب وتشوف وترون هل هي
موائمه لجسم الانسان في الفضاء كما هي في
الارض ام لا يعني بشكل بالضبط بالضبط يعني
في في عده يعني نتائج نتوقع احنا نتوقع
صراحه يعني كميات هايله من المعلومات عن
نشاط عشرات الالاف من الجينات وكيف تتغير
بين الفضاء وبين وبين الارض يعني توقعاتكم
هي تغير يعني ان شاء الله فيها تغير اكيد
ما نعرف
يعني هو هذا المحك في الموضوع وفي جميع
الاحوال كلها عباره عن يعني مهمه سواء
تغيرت باقل او تغيرت اكثر لانه يعطينا
فكره عن كيفيه
استخدام سواء نقص عمر الحمض الربيع النووي
او زاد طيب كما تشاهد عزيزي خالد ومشاهدي
قناه العربيه هذه هذا المختبر والذي نشاهد
الان ترصد كاميرا العربيه من داخل هذا
المختبر كاول كاميرا ترصد من داخل مختبر
طبي لبرنامج رواد الفضاء وهي الهيئه
السعوديه
الفضاء التي تقوم بالاشراف على هذه
التجارب البحثيه ونشاهد ايضا كادر طبي
كامل يقوم باجراء عده بحوث يعني اليوم يا
دكتور نتكلم ونشاهد الان نرصد كاميرا
العربيه هذه البحوث ولكن هناك سؤال مهم
رايدي الفضاء ريانه وعلي
ليس مختصين طبيا وليس هم ايضا دكاتره او
يعملون في المجال الطبي كيف سوف يتم ايصال
او كيف سوف يتم تطبيق هذه البحوث في
الفضاء سؤال جيد سؤال جيد في الحقيقه الان
تقوم الدكتور وجدان الاحمدي هي احد اعضاء
الفريق العلمي موجود الان بولايه كلور
كلورايد بامريكا لعمل محاكاه باستخدام نفس
التجهيزات ونفس المستلزمات الموجوده في
المحطه الدوليه الفضائيه عشان نتاكد بكل
دقه
وايضا بالوقت ثم بعد ذلك تم تدريب رائده
الفضاء ورائده الفضاء على على هذه على نفس
التجارب هذا الذي يقومون الذي سيقومون
فيها في المحطه الفضائيه الدولية كنا
نتكلم يا دكتور انه بعض الاجهزه المستخدمه
في هذا المختبر هي اجهزه نوعيه السعوديه
من دول القلائل التي تمتلك هذه الاجهزه
هو اهم شيء صراحه النواحي العلميه فاحنا
متخصصين في عمر الحمض النووي المناسب
المعروفين داني دوليا في الموضوع هذا وعلى
سبيل
المثال يعني
قمنا بغسل التغييرات اللي حاصله في
السرطان وفي الالتهابات والان حان الان
المعرفه اللي ممكن تحصل في الفضاء شكرا لك
يا دكتور خالد رغم ان الحديث شيق معك هو
حديث طبي بحث ولكن سوف نسهل الامر
للمشاهدين اليوم السعوديه عندها عده بحوث
طبيه وفي مجالات مختلفه ايضا ولكن بما
اننا نتواجد في مختبر طبي اليوم هؤلاء
الباحثين وكذلك الفريق البحثي هو يقوم
بتجربه بعض الخصائص لجسم الانسان وكيف هي
مواءمتها عندما يكون في الفضاء وايضا من
خلال بعض استخدام الجينات وبعض ايضا
الامور او الطرق البحثيه الطبيه طبعا
العربيه كانت تواكب ايضا ترصد عمليه
استخدام هذه العناصر وهذه الجزيئات
الحيويه داخل هذا المختبر الواقع في مركز
الملك فيصل او في مركز الابحاث في مستشفى
الملك فيصل في العاصمه السعوديه الرياض
وكذلك ايضا لا ننسى ان هناك مختبرات اخرى
داخل السعوديه تقوم السعوديه
بتنفيذ مجالات اخرى سواء مجالات جيولوجيه
او كذلك مجالات في بيئيه وكذلك في
العمليات الحيويه او العمليات والمتغيرات
المناخيه التي تطرا على العالم الان و
داخل الك ره الارضيه